en france c'est un enfant sur deux qui
arrivent au collège sans savoir nager
trois cents enfants de moins de 6 ans
sont également victimes de la noyade
chaque année face à ce constat sophie
kamoun ex nageuse olympique s'est engagé
aux côtés de sept nageurs de haut niveau
dans le programme majeur et citoyen
objectif apprendre aux enfants à nager
et on s'est dit qu'en tant que ancien
sportif de haut niveau ancien nageur de
haut niveau et il était de notre devoir
de
mettre notre pierre un petit peu à
l'édifice sur sur le savoir nager
c'était une cause évidemment nationale
aujourd'hui vous avez 259 gamins du
département qui vont être initiés à la
natation pour certains
conforté dans ce qu'ils savent faire
pour pour d'autres la cause de ces
chiffres alarmants l'inégalité d'accès à
la pratique être en contact avec les
enfants qui sont souvent dans des
quartiers
défavorisés sont peut dire c'est à dire
qui n'ont pas accès aux piscines par
manque de moyens de temps les transports
qui prennent trop de temps nageurs et
citoyens il ya d'un côté la natation
mais aussi toutes ces valeurs de
citoyenneté c'est un enjeu de vie la
natation que de savoir nager d'abord
pour pour éviter de se noyer cqfd mais
aussi sur les vertus les vertus du sport
démocratiser la natation en s'amusant
c'est la volonté de ses nageurs qui
comme bien rendre cette journée de
partage de transmission plaisante pour
tout le monde c'est extrêmement ludique
le but c'est que les enfants se sentent
bien sentent en confiance pour qu' il
puisse revenir derrière ou en dessous ou
ce avant la fête et 26 en fermant pas
peu après on est on est jeune âge il
sort de l'eau et après on recommence qui
est bien de là j'ai comme ça au moins 30
des nouvelles choses c'est vraiment le
but faire des petits ateliers d'être là
avec eux ce soit le plus vite possible
le un amusement une partie de plaisir
qui ait aucune contrainte le programme
va se démultiplier dans d'autres villes
menthe et les mureaux vont participer
l'année prochaine et tout le département
devrait être de la partie après les jo
de 2024